rossi you're gonna take us through a
recipe
i'm gonna make you something inspired by
my dad used to make all the time
he called it the hash gosh darn whatever
was in the gosh darn fridge was going in
the hash so let's get
started put a little oil in your pan oil
in the pan
we are making a delicious hash dish so
we're going to take potatoes these are
just frozen hash browns right and that
you have in the middle these are your
favorite i know you have some in the
freezer so we're going to put these in
the pan with a little salt some pepper
the thing about hash like this is there
are no rules it's really what you have
left in the refrigerator and it's a
great way to use some vegetables that
maybe you had as a side dish a couple
nights ago or that about to go bad yeah
because the best way to save money in
the kitchen is to not waste anything and
i believe
that this recipe would retail in total
at about ten dollars and below
absolutely think about potatoes yeah
they're like a dollar something a pound
and they stretch everything out they
stretch out my butt
a little bit
all right let's talk about what we're
throwing in here drew i have some things
from my refrigerator like the other
night i roasted some sweet potatoes
they're going in boom go in potatoes i
had some leftover broccoli and carrots
those are going in
what about you know you make some like
saute peppers and onions you have those
left over in the little tupperware thing
i like mine a little sausage but yes
those are going into
all right we just keep stirring we're
gonna take some fresh spinach and throw
those in there as well drew
and then you know i was thinking about
what's in your refrigerator all the time
and just to prove that there's no rules
when it comes to hash you can do
anything what if you had some leftover
macaroni and cheese drew in your
refrigerator throw it in let's go
no into the hash now come on
into the hash
okay
so we have another pan over here just
let that sit there on warm put some oil
in this pan over here
because what we're going to do is we're
going to fry an egg to put on top of
this when it's all done
right oh i know
i love frying an egg i think so too it
gives me like good morning
kind of vibe right
salt and pepper your egg and then i like
to just take a spoon with some of this
oil and just sort of
put it over the yolk it just helps it
cook so we have our hash over here right
all the elements come together our egg
is cooking but what about this if we
want to take our hash to the very next
level do you ever look in the fridge and
see some herbs that are about to go bad
yes what do you do with that i hate
wasting that money well let's go to our
blender over here i have some parsley
some cilantro some chai sage thyme and
rosemary none of that no just cilantro
parsley um
chives scallions we're to put them in
our blender i'm going to squeeze some
lemon into this drew
lemon going in well did it come oh here
it is okay
where is all my juice
yeah no this was weird no i didn't
realize you were supposed to do that and
it came out like that i know
so here's how this is how the pilgrims
did it i just squeeze like this and hold
the seas in my hand okay that's how it
take it like that that's how most sexy
chefs do at rossi so i think you're
doing it right okay put a little bit of
red pepper flakes in this some salt and
pepper as well in our herb mixture
we want to pour a little oil into this a
little olive oil as well not too much
you can always add more but you can't
take it out okay what we're doing here
is we're making
oh hi do your thing girl
oh
yes i was so into it okay this is like a
chimichurri situation and this is done
all right are you ready to assemble i am
okay grab your little bowl over there
let's take some of our
hash that has the vegetables and the mac
and cheese okay i need like a scooper
okay so i have my bowl of hash i'm gonna
top this
with my fried egg look at that
and then ready for this drew
hold on okay she can do it she can do it
she can do it she did it
yes drew
thank you okay
now let's take some of our chimichurri
sauce just get your spoon in there
and do a little dress and do a little
drizzle on top look at look how pretty
this is to this color beautiful and that
really does add a nice color such
acidity to the dough
you ready to taste are you ready
get in there there we go i'm getting
right in there with that yolk
you can taste how bright that
chimichurri is the acid and that
brings the entire dish to life and you
think about this was all made
with leftovers and i have one more tip
for you this is beautiful
if you have
if you have extra chimichurri sauce you
can pour this into an ice tray
and freeze this and then use it later
wow
yes break it into your stir fry next
time you're sauteing chicken whatever
just do this is all stuff that you were
going to throw away
roxy that's brilliant
well
you can make this recipe
for under ten dollars yourself visit the
drewberrymarshow.com for the full
ingredients and as rossi said play with
what you've got
[Music]